right so
copic procession which I want to share
with you he said basically angular
momentum is always thought of as a
vector so if you have for example
helicopter rotor system you curl your
fingers in the direction of the rotation
and then the your thumb pointing up is
the vector that represents the angular
momentum so if for example you push up
at the back of the rotor disk that's
like a turn in this direction so now you
have a vector going this way and the new
angular momentum is some kind of sum of
those two so the sideways vector and the
up vector may be a little bit like this
and the new rotation of the disc ends up
looking this way so that's the
gyroscopic precession that the new arc
looks like it's been pushed up from a
point 90 degrees more advanced in the
disk
so if you can remember that so how so I
guess for the airplane propeller let's
say we could do rotating this way
clockwise
rotating this way so the vector is going
out if we push on the if we push on the
side that's like rotating this direction
so it's up so the sum is a little bit up
like this as if it's been pushed from
the bottom be glad you're not a physics
major I guess you don't like that MIT
used to require two years of physics oh
the clicker is not working oh maybe it
is oh ye of little faith
all right play planning so let's stick
with the same challenge that we looked
at before which is getting to Bennington
Vermont so you have a sectional chart
and you can draw a line I did this with
skyvector I want to prove to you that it
can be done so we basically say look we
want to go from Bedford which is here we
put our ruler on the chart it almost
goes to Bennington over here do you see
that more state on the chart and you can
see the ruler is good for about 88
nautical miles so it doesn't quite
stretch to the 90 but it can be done and
you can also see this protractor here we
can get some idea if we kind of slide it
up and down the line until we get a line
of longitude we can eventually see okay
its course a true course of two eight
something that looks like
all right we'll figure that out using
electronic tools but I just wanted to
show you that it can be done so the key
is here you are making sure that the you
know draw this out with the pencil and
continue to the line and then for the
protractor part you make sure you put it
on one of these lines of constant
latitude or longitude which gives you a
an accurate reference to true east-west
or true north-south so the tools as you
just saw the classical tools for this
are the New York sectional chart which I
brought that plotter essentially the
ruler in protractor combined the e6b
calculator which we played around with a
little bit yesterday what's the plan for
our plan though we want to make sure
that we're going to find an altitude
that doesn't interfere with terrain or
with which terrain won't interfere want
to make sure that you know we're not
going through restricted airspace that's
active or if we are going through you
know class Charlie airspace or clouds
bravo airspace that we're aware of that
an event so we can make sure to be in
contact with air traffic control a lot
of cross-country flights basically all
of mine I call up air traffic control
anyway and request VFR advisories it's
an optional service but that way you're
pretty unlikely to blunder into airspace
that you shouldn't be in we're gonna
check wet and then actually that reminds
me of something a comment you know this
ground school stuff I think it turned
some people off of flying per se that
people who are really interested in the
stick and rudder stuff they say you know
God I don't want to learn about all that
airspace and I want to deal with all
those air traffic controllers I just
want to fly that kind of flying you know
it's hard to do at Hanscom field which
is the ninth busiest airport in the
Northeast
you know after airports such as Logan
LaGuardia and JFK but it's very easy to
do in a lot of parts of the country you
know if you're out west there most
airports you know there's you know
thousands of airports in the u.s. that
don't have control towers that don't
have any traffic that are surrounded by
Class G airspace you do whatever you
want so that kind of flying exists to
get the private you know the FAA wants
to make sure that you've at least
learned this stuff so you know if you
become that kind of you know backwoods
pilot that you don't blunder into a JFK
God's probably airspace
but that kind of fun flying does exist
the other thing I wanted to say is in
all kinds of flying education there's an
emphasis on the hazardous there's an
emphasis on you saw some of that I think
yesterday with mark you know he talked
to God I do this you got to scan for
this because you don't have a mid-air
collision you know midair collisions
were one percent of accidents last year
according to the null report if you're
interested in these statistics the AOPA
safety foundation ASF or Air Safety
Institute I guess they have this thing
called an all report nal every year they
analyze all the kinds of accidents that
have occurred but midair collisions are
exceptionally rare like I said one
percent of accidents maybe three percent
of fatal accidents so you know flying
this tends to be pretty forgiving
usually most people that have an
accident have made three or four
mistakes it's not like one little
mistake it's going to generally get you
into trouble
so I don't want people to think that you
know it's all bureaucracy and
regulations all the time when you're up
in the air or that you know at any
moment they are playing can suddenly
stall and spin that kind of stuff it's
just extremely rare you know if you're
flying a cirrus you're nowhere near the
stall at any fate in any phase of flight
as long as you're doing things more or
less by the book okay so anyway this is
our plan and we'll we'll follow this
kind of step by step
okay so if we look at the sectional
chart we can see that there's these see
that 41 that tells you that if you're at
4,100 feet you have a little bit of
clearance from the terrain not enough
for flying on instruments but enough for
flying visually we can also see the only
real airspace
that's on our route is the class bravo
airspace itself and that goes from 4,000
feet up to 7,000 feet over top of
Hanscom field so as long as we're in
contact with Hanscom tower and we're not
climbing in some kind of fighter jet
we're gonna be be clear of bravo
airspace and also if we have a plane
with the GPS vor receiver combined and
part of it fails you can see there's all
these vo ARS around here including one
very close to the airport that we're
going to so we're not going to get lost
even if we can't find Venus like Captain
Sully can't talk to air traffic control
and I can't use our GPS I look out the
window there's a lot of actually a lot
of times we send solvating students to
Keene New Hampshire because it's right
next to Mount Monadnock and we figure
well they probably can't get lost if
there's only one big mountain sticking
up by itself right next to the airport
all right it's always good to have a
plan what if you cross the mountains and
the airport is hard to find if the
airport is covered in some fog if
somebody you know has driven huge
lawnmower onto the middle of the runway
and gotten stuck what do we do so it's
always good to have a back-up plan
here's Albany remember I told you that
story about the Cirrus hero so he wanted
to go here to rinse Olear RPI and here's
the huge Albany Airport with a wonderful
fvo it's very inexpensive cheaper than
Hanscom actually for fuel and here's the
airport that he was thinking about see
it says is it 2700 foot runway but due
to the displaced
it's actually shorter that doesn't have
a control tower that si means it's a
common traffic advisory frequency Albany
of course is a class Charlie Airport so
has all kinds of great services anyway
so for our alternate you know things
aren't going well I want to be drinking
free coffee at the FBO and borrowing the
crew car and going to a nearby
restaurant not you know standing out
there in the wind wondering why nobody
except the Rensselaer County Airport
okay so we found an alternate Airport
not required unless you're IFR but
always good to think about I'm not a
reasonable alternate for Bennington
would be just to turn or make a u-turn
and go back two hands come because it's
not really all that far all right we
look at this we can look at the chart
supplement for Bedford if that's not our
home Airport remember this gives all the
information about radio frequencies and
runways similarly for Bennington Vermont
we can see it's a 3700 foot runway not
too much else that's interesting here
except if it's going to be nighttime it
says the lights won't be on we should
activate the medium intensity runway
lights on the CTF frequency so if we
click the microphone five times all the
airport lights will come on that'll be
nice otherwise not too exciting looks
like this runway is slightly sloped
that's one thing about Vermont see it's
a 0.9 percent slope up so that's going
to have a slight effect on our
performance okay so in the old days we
would just call this 1-800 number and
get our weather briefing or if we were
enroute we might call you can see
Bridgeport radios available here on the
vor the vor for Providence indicates
that if you want to talk to Bridgeport
radio you call them on one to two point
six so we can also talk to Bridgeport
radio although you know if we're going
to do a flight plan we
get most of our stuff done beforehand we
can look at our air mats this is an
older slide this is not current data but
at least at some time there was an error
net for IFR and mountain obscuration so
in that case we might consider deferring
our flight
there was also air met tango for
turbulence so look at this is it time to
freak out
[Music]
well it says moderate turbulence tastes
to always say occasional moderate now I
mean nothing ever they put the dump of
the occasional in there but really that
means there may be turbulence below
8,000 feet usually when you get about
through half of the turbulence forecast
altitude it smooths out considerably so
if it says as ever mentioned yesterday
the turbulence forecast goes up into the
flight levels it's a pretty ugly day it
goes up to 8,000 feet that's kind of a
standard slightly windy newing one day
all right and you know you might get a
few bumps climbing up to 4 or 5,000
meters
look at this listed meet ours so once as
I said yesterday once you get used to
reading these this is actually I prefer
this format it's very compact you can
just zip down we can just assume these
are long our route of flight forget them
in a briefing format so we can see oh
it's gusting you know it's 9 gusting 19
knots it's gusty day when we get to
Bennington it's 3 0 0 at 5 knots
10 miles broken 7,000 that's pretty
reasonable terminal forecasts you heard
about that yesterday but again we get
them in our brief err from the briefer
or the briefing format along our route
of flight remember our goal is to
maintain VFR weather minimums again you
can see how much more challenging this
is then in a jet if you were in a jet
you would say well I don't need to
maintain VFR because I'll file IFR and I
don't need to remain clear of icing
because I can turn on the DI sink unless
it's incredibly severe
but you guys will have this challenge at
least until you decide that you want to
get your instrument rating or you want
to bring along the copilot whose
instrument rated winds aloft is very
important for this flight our for this
flight planning task we can see lost and
we don't have Albany winds might be the
best so the winds are coming from
three-30 more or less in our face at 28
knots and the temperature outside is
minus 10 so if it is cloudy
that means there's a risk of icing so in
a piper warrior or cirrus I wouldn't do
this trip on this day unless I thought
that I could remain clear of the clouds
due to that you know if you saw that at
6,000 feet it was above zero that would
be great okay relevant NOTAMs
the vazhi see that on the bottom
the Vasi at DD H is out of service so
that means we're not going to have our
visual reference for the glide slope to
the runway you know if it's your home
Airport that's not a big deal if it's
daytime at an unfamiliar airport that's
not a huge deal nighttime at an
unfamiliar Airport that's kind of a
problem so you might consider you know
nighttime it's better to treat that like
instrument flight you might not want to
go actually in my airline days we got to
this part at night we were really
delayed for a variety of reasons but
anyway so we get to this Airport in
Michigan at night and I'm flying left
traffic from the right seat so I can't
really see the airport that well in this
Canada regional jet which I've just
barely learned to fly mostly in the sim
exclusively and this M the first flight
and the real aircraft was with
passengers in the back and runways under
construction so the instrument landing
system which gives you the glide slope
reference that's out of service because
it would lead you to a part of the
runway that's closed
and the VAS and Pappy that are normally
there at this big airport and Saginaw or
wherever it was that's also out of
service so it's just a pure visual
approach based on the configuration of
the runway lights and the geometry and
how it looks this like you were flying a
Cessna or a piper in this jet so you
know we got on the ground and like I
said I'm hiding from the right seat I
should perhaps have just turned it over
to the captain and said you know this is
a little beyond my skill level but I
wanted to practice so I did it
and you know we turned off the runway
and nobody was more surprised than I and
we were on the ramp safe and sound we
got out of the airplane this passenger
was irate it's just he thought somehow
it was my fault he saw me talking you
know having dinner with a friend and the
turmoil I thought like I was the reason
for the delay the flight was held up for
my dinner and he was enraged and I you
know I thought to myself this guy has no
idea how lucky used to be alive with
somebody like me and controls no visual
references of any kind the first time at
that Airport you know going 145 knots
was the slowest speed that we were going
at anytime
deserve circumstance later two limbs
were found say okay
on the other runway you don't want to
land with a tailwind in general and
there may not be we could go back but
there may not be a Vasi on the other
side usually airports have sort of one
runway that they really love
actually that's not that's interesting
first of all they don't even have a Vasi
they have a Pappy on both sides so yeah
actually that's that's a good example of
decision-making if the winds not too bad
and if it's and actually at nighttime
the wind usually quiets down so yeah
perfect example of good decision-making
just use the other runway why not all
right
so we use the plotter you saw some of
that we draw our line you can see there
we're referencing the plotter to true
north and we get well this is not for
the pennant example unfortunately we got
a true course of zero three eight to
some other Airport here's what I did
want to show you you find some prominent
landmarks along the route we talked
about that yesterday in the piloted
section so things you can identify from
the air you get your blank navigation
Log form you pick an altitude so to
avoid I mean this is one reason why
mid-air collisions are exceedingly rare
people are above 3,000 feet above the
ground higher than 3,000 feet above the
ground and you get up to your cruising
your conventional cruising altitude so
if you're on instruments it's going to
be whole thousands so you'll fly on
instruments at six thousand eight
thousand for example if you're on a
westbound course and you'll fly you know
five seven nine if you're eastbound and
then just add five hundred if you're VFR
so air airplanes at low altitudes that
are cruising are almost always separated
by five hundred feet
and therefore you know the conflicts
tend to occur very near airports and the
conflicts also tend to occur there's one
exception to that role on days when
there's a low cloud layer like at 3,000
feet for example or 2500 feet and
everybody who's VFR is trying to go
under the clouds that's when you might
see other airplanes and have to be
vigilant but again you can call air
traffic control and ask for advisories
or now you know vert within within by
January 1st of 2020 everybody was early
80s B so I have a box in there it says
squawking at you let me tell you that
when you land at Burning Man your
traffic your fancy traffic warning
system will get very upset indeed we had
warnings Burning Man has this it's not
like Oshkosh that's super well organized
they have people converging from three
by design from three different
directions to a single point flying a
pattern that's 500 feet above the runway
instead of the conventional thousand or
1500 for turbine powered aircraft and
then you're landing on a place that's
not normally considered a runway so in
the Pilatus we had the terrain warning
system going nuts
it didn't know that there was a runway
there and we also had the traffic system
going that's because they were enough
trying we didn't have a TSB but we had
enough transponder equipped aircraft
around us that it could see them all so
that was pretty upsetting not as
upsetting as not as upset as the cool
Burning Man people were to see me but my
friend had a good time
yeah this fight should really contain
that exception that it's only up to
3,000 feet above the ground it's only
above it's 3,000 feet above the ground
[Music]
3001 feet above the ground and above so
you can if you have a low cloud or the
question was what if you have low clouds
how can you do this the answer is if
you're 3,000 feet in below these
conventional cruising altitudes said
don't apply okay oh yeah so this is just
an elaboration of that so we're gonna be
on a magnetic course that's generally
westbound so we'll pick 4,500 feet do we
need oxygen for our flight the answer is
no that's a good thing if you are gonna
be flying above 10,000 feet though if
you were doing a charter flight you
would need oxygen so you might ask
yourself well if that's good for the
Charter crowd why isn't it good for me I
think that it
[Music]
especially as you get older you know
people tend to get a lot more sharp if
they keep the cabin altitude 5,000 and
below or use supplemental oxygen a
little airplane alright there's your
chart 91 2 1 1 you might be asked about
that all right let's go back so we've
got I guess in this flight planning
example we've done 6,500 feet so you can
see we've filled in the altitude we're
going to climb go to 6,500 feet our true
course is 287 and you can see these
fixes a beam fitchburg crossing the
river finding some reservoir finally
landing at Bennington so we'll just see
what the folks these fives were built
before Tina and I took over the course
all right as I said pick those winds
aloft it says reporting points actually
that should be changed that's inaccurate
and that winds aloft reporting points
these are always forecast the there's no
you know balloons up there with sensors
to tell you exactly what the winds are
ok maybe somebody can remind me after
the class to change that ok so we fill
in the forecast wind and then we use our
actually no we do the piper we're gonna
need to find that air speed so we look
up the performance tables for our piper
warrior or we bought or we pay up for
that Geronimo app that you saw I don't
know if they have a warrior version but
maybe they do and we pulled the numbers
out of there I'll just let you digest
this for a moment
alright it looks like we're going to
burn about to the important takeaways
from here we're gonna burn about two and
a half gallons and the climb two gallons
and the cruise and you can see how many
minutes it's gonna take to climb and
descend so they'll just go into our
calculation of the whole time alright so
we've got that in there our true air
speeds for see we've got our true air
speeds for climbing and descending what
about cruising so we use the performance
charts to figure out that we're going to
be going along here at about one hundred
and twelve knots before the wind hits us
[Music]
we add that to our plan we've got all
these distances we've measured that with
our protractor and ruler with our
plotter so you've got the distances for
each leg we filled in the true air
speeds okay now we do the wind
correction so remember if we're reading
everything isn't true if we're hearing
it on the ATIS a sauce or from the
control tower you can just say wind
check please
you don't have to say your tail number
or anything and the tower is gonna
broadcast back to you you know winds
three one zero at one two okay so here's
an example I can do it in real time also
on the dock camera let me show you this
so if the winds from two one zero at
twenty knots and you're trying to go
south at a true airspeed at one forty
seven it's a good cirrus speed you line
up two one zero two the true index and
then we're gonna draw a little twenty
knot vector here it really doesn't
matter where we start we're gonna draw a
twenty knot vector here so there's a
little point for 20 knots up
that represents our wind some people
actually draw it as a vector imagine a
little vector here or actually I guess
it would be going this way then we
rotate so that we show our true course
so we're trying to go south and the wind
is from this direction and we've lined
it up see how there's 140 150 so that's
roughly at 147 so it tells us with this
little subtraction here we're going to
be going to slightly slower than 130
knots or 129 as it says on the slide and
we're going to need to steer about 4
degrees off the true course does that
all make sense
it's a little graphical calculator
basically and the idea is you're
starting with a vector that represents
the wind you can play around with this
as a break and I'll also try I'll try
using them and dock camera and you'll
see just how much a person can forget in
17 years or 18 years okay now we filled
this in we've said okay there's our true
airspeed here's our wind correction
angle where is our ground speed oh
there's our ground speed okay so from
the ground speed and the leg distance of
course we'll be able to determine the
time now this is the exciting part since
we're only going 90 knots we can figure
out you know for any given leg length
how long that's going to take
so we do that eventually we'll fill it
in oh yeah we got to get the magnetic
variation so our true heading is
supposed to be 293 or 283 I guess in the
cruise and we add in the west variation
remember east as weas east as least west
is best so we've added in that magnetic
variation and that's the magnetic
heading
if we happen to have oh yeah there's a
point to this slide so what if we take
all that metal fishing gear and throw it
into the float plane that might actually
affect the compass especially if you're
up in Alaska it was until about 2000 one
or two it was required to carry a gun in
your airplane at all times when you were
flying in Alaska us you're in the
traffic pattern at an airport you know
doing flight training or something so if
you had your you know huge rightful you
know up in the front of your aircraft
then your company yeah just like could
be thrown off by the gun that you were
required to carry who knows why you had
to carry a gun why do you have to carry
a gun in your Cessna
bears that's right anyway they change
the law so now you can be a pacifist you
had to have ammo to actually I think
they could bust you if you didn't have
ammo for your gun all right I have a
friend actually I was going to Alaska
and the regulation was just being
sunsets I thought well maybe I should
bring a gun with me so I asked a friend
who's a gun enthusiast you know like
what would be the right gun he said oh
you need the Spinelli shotgun with you
know automatically reloads the shells
and you can fire it off you know whole
bunch of shotgun shells and ones it's
like you know like whoa where could I
get 100 he said oh I've got five so I
can even just borrow one of mine okay so
yeah here's another East Coast arrow
club plane you got to calculate your
time it might be pretty fast
that's from Oshkosh they brought the b1
actually this b1 wasn't they were they
ran away from that huge thunderstorm
that I showed you so I went through the
thunderstorms and then $9 10 and the b1
left and the b1 taking them off was
louder than anything that happened
during the thunderstorm it's crazy loud
all right so we've got it all filled out
it is going to take us
it looks like it's gonna take us a toll
of one hour
does that make sense yeah I guess about
90 knots about 90 miles so yeah that
makes sense okay we calculate the fuel
burn so it's going to take us a minimum
of 11 gallons or so to get there and we
want to have a half-hour reserve I can
tell you that's pretty scary to see the
gauges down that low so I think a plan
for a one-hour reserve is about as low
as you would ever want to plan and then
beyond that we should add some fuel to
get to our alternate if necessary in the
instrument flying world you plan to fly
to your destination fly to your
alternate actually fly to your
destination fly an instrument approach
kind of fly the mist flying all to the
alternate and then fly around for you
know another 45 minutes to an hour after
that all right what about the VFR fuel
requirements so again the you know the
effe minimums are pretty scanty 30
minutes for the day time 45 at night for
helicopters or even less 20 minutes and
30 minutes 20 minutes day and 30 minutes
at night okay wait and bounce that's off
the tail of a Piper Cub at Oshkosh
unfortunately we don't have that in the
Warriors which nobody loves quite as
much so the glorious plan here some of
these older airplanes actually have
better payloads when they're fully
fueled than the latest and greatest
because they're not crammed with as much
helpful avionics anyway so the original
warrior this plan is to take two heavy
people in the front four hundred pounds
total to more virtuous people in the
back and 50 pounds of bags and you see
the max gross weight is 23 25 on this
Piper so can we do it you're gonna have
a long nice to say tedious lecture on
weight and balance later so we won't
belabor this but
if you look at that loading the
prospective loading I think we should
expect that it's going to be within the
center of gravity limits because the
heavier people are in front and the real
issue is whether we're overweight or not
so we are actually overweight see that
23 34
and it's 23 25 is the maximum so we're
about 10 pounds overweight how about are
we out of CG we're at about 92 inches
and you can see here that the CG
envelope goes to about 93 I guess it
goes exactly to 93
so the CG is fine but the weight is too
high what's the question oh yeah so
that's a good question where do you find
all them weight information about the
weight and balance that you're gonna use
for this calculation so remember we
talked about arrow you have to have the
airworthiness certificate the
registration the owners the owners
manual I think is the best way to think
of the oh and that NW is to weight in
balance so it has to be in the aircraft
it's usually just in the same binder as
the pilots operating handbook or the afm
so it's there it's specific to the
airplane and in the airplane will get
reweighed periodically and if any kind
of equipment has changed out they throw
it in there but also these apps I mean
the arm of the you know rear seats and a
piper warrior that doesn't change from
aircraft to aircraft so you just punch
that in you just punch and I think the
total moment and the total weight of the
empty airplane into an app like Geronimo
and then it will calculate the rest of
it for you but it already has the arms
for each position in the aircraft
remember that's just a distance from the
pick some arbitrary point on the
aircraft like just in front of the
propeller and you're just looking at the
number of inches
back from the propeller for example that
makes sense
okay so we're overweight will it fly ten
pounds overweight what do you guys think
it will and you might actually fly up to
about 30 percent overweight generally
because I think people get waivers to
take off with an extra fuel tank when
they're trying to cross the Atlantic or
the Pacific Ocean or something however
it's an especially bad idea to go
overweight if its turbulent because the
aircraft is designed for handling
turbulence you know up to its gross
weight so that's one thing that happens
when people fly over gross is that it
tends to strain things that shouldn't be
strained so it's a bad practice as a
regular matter and of course you're also
reducing your performance margins but
you know on a winter day in New England
you have you know ample power so it's
not like the airplane won't fly but it's
not legal to fly and you know I actually
you know I try never to exceed the gross
weight what was the question it does go
up with weight that's a good question if
the maneuvering speed goes up with
weight you know why do you start bending
things I think that you know it's not
just G loads that'll bend the aircraft
it's also the overall weight of the
stuff in there I don't know that's a
good question for a real course 16 or
course to engineer what do you guys
think that's that that's what I've heard
though if you load it if you load it up
it'll
that's true but I have heard that you
know if you're in smooth air you'll
probably get away with it for quite a
long time all right
but you also you want that performance
margin you know if you get if you get
into a downdraft off the lee side of a
mountain you know you want some kind of
reasonable climb rate and you know if
it's one pound over gross you're gonna
be good the higher you go over a gross
weight you know the less performance
margin you have that's why training is
so great in a forest cedar helicopter or
airplane because you have a lot of power
to get yourself quickly out of you know
an uncomfortable situation whatever it
is because of those two empty seats in
the back all right
takeoff performance we figured out that
we only need a thousand feet of ground
roll and there are really no obstacles
at Hanscom field so the 2,000 foot
number isn't even relevant we have 7,000
feet of runway so we're good there
landing we're gonna clear a 50-foot
obstacle which we can expect to find
probably in Vermont they have plenty of
trees and Hills so let's make sure we
have at least you know 1500 feet of mark
of runway plus mrz which we do so the
book says we command in 40% of the
runway and remember I told you that for
airline operations you try to make sure
you can land in at least 60% of the
runway so we're good there here's the
sample flight plan form at the bottom I
say fun fun exercises to look at the
ICAO the international flight plan form
I should probably put it in a slide it's
so complicated that there's nobody on
the planet I think they can really fill
it out that computers will do it for you
anyway here you're just telling it's
been in use probably since the 50s
you're just telling the FAA what kind of
aircraft you have a few things when they
ask you what type it is that would be
something like sr20 for a cirrus or PA
eight for a piper warrior true airspeed
is going to be you know as computed not
indicated but corrected for your
pressure and density altitude also on
the aircraft type there's a slash for
special equipment so if you have a GPS
on board which you know is no long
well it's no longer special but anyway
you're supposed to put slash golf so
sr20 slash golf so the controllers if
you're if you actually talking to you
they know that you know they can tell
you to go direct to some fixed it's only
in the GPS anybody find the ICAO form
who wants to fill it out all right good
all right let's say let's do it 300 well
let me let me let's go over here to the
dock camera for a moment so you got your
handy dandy pencil and let's say the
wind is from the north so we just pick
any old spot here and let's say it's a
thirty knot wind so it won't be so the
wind's blowing from the north at 30
knots that makes sense
okay and we want to go south with the
wind true north so now we say well
what's the airspeed of our series it's
about 150 knots and then we can read at
the bottom of our vector and now that
wind vector has blown us to 180 knots
is everybody happy with that all right
so yeah so we put the dot on it and it
is explained up here at the top okay
let's try some other situations what if
we want to go west that wind from the
north again we put it here on the 180
that wind from the north oh sorry we put
it on the 150 so we're cruising at 150
so notice remember I said this is act
this is actually reflected here that a
beam wind is a slight reduction in
ground speed because they're also trying
to fly into the wind so you can see here
our ground speed has been reduced from
150 to about 148 or 147 and we need a
wind correction you can see here this is
a 10 degree line so we're going to need
a wind correction of about 12 degrees
about this dear right about 12 degrees
anyway and if we're actually let's see
the wind was from the south
oh no the wind was from the north so if
we're trying to go north then it becomes
really simple we put it on 150 and now
we're only going 120 knots alright I
think I survived that that was one of my
big fears about this class so I learned
to do that in oh I learned to do that in
2001 and the fall of I say well I guess
probably yeah probably in early 2002
scary huh how much people forget alright
I want to show you I just want to show
you one of these sites okay so here we
are in skyvector we can store some
flight plans because I am logged in so
I'll open an existing plan and I'll say
I want to go from Bedford to Bennington
oops
today at 20 Allu which is three o'clock
local time so as soon as the class is
over we teleport to Hanscom field the
instructor is already preflighted the
warrior so we jump in and we go all
right so here we have I think you saw
this before here are the points that I
picked out as being may be easy to
recognize from the air along our trip
and we say okay well what's the what's
the weather going to be like we just
click here
and we get an official briefing from a
flight service station voi LA
there's ooh special at Bedford won eight
wins one eight zero at 17 gusting 26 for
snapchat miles of visibility light rain
mist overcast 800 temperatures 13 dew
points 12 so that's not much of a
temperature dew points wet and sure
enough the clouds are pretty close to
the ground right with a one degree split
you'd expect the clouds to be close peak
wind was 1 8 0 at 2 7 mm look at this
terminal forecast the longer the
terminal forecasts usually the more
upsetting the weather is it's going to
be down to one statute mile heavy rain
plus RA overcast 800 and it's going to
be gusting 38 that's at 1800 Zulu
so that's forecast for our I think we're
departing at 20 a Zulu we said right so
that's the forecast for our departure
time that's not looking so good the good
news is there is no
really upsetting NOTAMs there say I
think that this is this new you can look
it up in the aim five five five for the
runway condition code 100% wet but I
think that mean as the breaking action
is still just fine as you'd expect for a
groove runway
alright so everything's good there how
about Bennington
that's what Oh the okay student asked
about the colored pins which I think by
which I think he means the pins of color
so the red is IFR weather conditions and
the blue I think is marginal VFR and you
can set that up in these layers so yes
e-text whether we're just inverting its
converting those texts weathers to two
graphics okay good question yeah so
anyway it's kind of an ugly day maybe
want to fly some other time however we
could follow the flight plan if we
wanted to and it also give us this
helpful little nav log here that we can
use in the aircraft so all that hard
work that we were doing with the e6b can
be done for us free and very easily and
very conveniently with just a couple
clicks on sky factor I see that Tina's
here so she's she's a huge for flight
plan where oh yeah there she is so Tina
will tell you maybe it would have been
even easier on floor flight but sky
vector you know sky vector does many
fewer things in for flight and therefore
the interface is simpler and of course
the for flight folks will be here at
three and I'm sure they'll tell you why
for flights better than sky vector
alright let's go back to the
presentation here
these are just some of my favorites like
I said there's a whole ton of these apps
question oh yeah the question is what
does it mean to file a flight plan
so the FAA has these computer system
these old mainframes I think for a while
they had Philips mean frame computers
you may not have heard of Philips as a
popular vendor of computer systems
that's because they exited the business
I think in the late 60s early 70s but
the FAA had all the software that was
running in folks machine code so they
were emulating the Philips mainframes on
more modern systems you know right up -
I don't know into the 2000s at least I'm
not sure if it's still that old Philips
code that takes your flight plan to
something similar so your flight plan
gets sent from whatever application
you're using I think - maybe leidos the
Lockheed Martin spin-off contractor that
took over flight service in 2005 I
believe it was and from there it goes
into some FAA computer system and it's
accessible to you know the controllers
if it's an instrument flight plan you
know they'll develop a rote route for
you if it's just a VFR flight plan
point-to-point and you're gonna activate
it and deactivate it manually it may
stay with the flight service station
because the controller's you know have
no reason to know about that or care
that into your question yes there's a
whole bunch of different places that can
enter the flight plan where it gets more
complicated and where I think an
application like for flight might come
in very handy is international flying so
if you go to Mexico or something you end
up physically walking over to the
control tower and there's you know
people who help you there they fill out
the forms on paper and you know it's
it's kind of fun you got a budget an
extra half hour before every departure
to fill out all the paperwork but
they're all nice people
yes the question is what if you have to
call in on the radio your flight plan
the flight server station what do you
provide you basically just they'll
prompt you if need be but some people on
their knee board or whatever will have
the elements of a flight plan and they
they you just you just read out you know
the same as the flight plan form you
know where you want to go what your what
your registration number is seven zero
seven whiskey Tango your type sr20 slash
golf how many souls on board how much
fuel you have all that other stuff and
they enter it in the system just as if
you've done it on the phone you can also
do it by calling that 1-800 WX brief
number you can do everything by phone
question all right let's see what else
we got in here suggested reading so far
61 and 91 is the stuff that you're going
to be tested on but you know it might
not be the best plan for prudence so for
example in Canada in Canada you need
special training and an endorsement at
least if not I think it might be a
rating you need special training and I
think a rating to fly at night VFR in
some countries VFR flight at night it's
just simply unauthorized as Tina
mentioned you have to file IFR I think
if you want to go flying around a night
in Mexico the four Forfar 135 they say
look you can't fly single pilot IFR with
no autopilot you have to you know have
some way of taking your hands off you
know and not having the airplane go
upside down on the clouds you yeah so
just look at those operating limitations
and when you know when you're doing your
flight plan just ask yourself you know
should I be something doing something
that's more aggressive than then what
the Charter and airline crews are
permitted to do alright so we can take
questions and meanwhile I'll show you
while you're thinking of your questions
here is
the planning well doesn't really show
the planning I guess some of the
planning we had to load up this pilatus
with sixty sea turtles I think that was
late November early December so you can
see there they are in the back of the
airplane there in these Chiquita banana
boxes here's the Garmin 650 in the front
of the airplane showing that we're just
entering Virginia I believe and we still
have two hours to go before we get to
anima City Florida we're getting 281
knots over the ground which is a little
bit of a tail wind that's unusual going
to Florida when we get there we get
treated like rock stars there's a TV
station there the turtles are here being
transferred and there's our cockpit at
night we flew back at night it was kind
of a long day maybe 7 a.m. to 9 p.m. or
something and there's one of our sea
turtle friends
you